voilà un modèle en direct de l'hôpital
de la pitié salpêtrière à paris
mona bonjour la france se situe dans une
phase de hauts plateaux c'est bien ça il
ya exactement la base de hauts plateaux
comme vous l'avez dit l'île de france et
le grand est sont elles les zones les
plus touchées
jérôme salma le directeur général de la
santé a annoncé des chiffres qui
indiquent et 7 162 morts supplémentaires
par rapport aux décomptes de lundi et un
bilan total de quinze mille sept cents
29 décès en comptant les hôpitaux et les
ehpad
ce soir les chiffres des morts à
domicile pourrait être donné en tout cas
le nombre de contaminations dépassent
elles deux les 100 milles à 100 3573
l'europe reste donc l'épicentre de cette
épidémie avec un million de cas et 80
mille décès il y a des bonnes nouvelles
il est important de les souligner en
cette période de pandémie à 27 milles
plus de 27000 personnes et guérissent
sont sortis des hôpitaux et 465 mille
personnes est guéri dans le monde entier
il y avait il ya quelques jours
l'intervention du président de la
république qui a suscité beaucoup de
réactions avec notamment cette date du
prolongement du confinement jusqu'au 11
mai c'est la condition pour faire
reculer le virus selon le président est
de la république pour l'instant personne
ne sait quelle sera la prochaine étape
à savoir après le 11 mai
merci mon âme ou dès lors pour ces
précisions en direct de l'hôpital de la
pitié salpêtrière à paris